Because of the tragic effects of the lobotomy and its over use, today's psycho
surgeries are only used, as a last resource after all other therapies are
proven to be uneffective. ECT is administered by passing electric current
through the brain in a order to induce a seizure. And ECT is administered by
placing electrodes on the head, and passing that electrical current through for
approximately one third to half a second. And the voltage ranges between 60 and
140 volts. Now this voltage is not lethal because it's delivered to the head,
however, if that voltage were delivered to the chest it would be lethal. Early
in its use, ECT often produced fractures, because a person was experiencing
seizure and convulsions. Therefore, today patients are given a muscle relaxant
and an anesthetic, before the ECT is administered. Thus what was once a violent
procedure due to the convulsions, shaking, and broken bones, now only results
in a slight tremor because of the muscle relaxant. Now, it may typically take
at least six to 12 sessions at ECT, before a person is relieved of their
depressive symptoms. In addition, after ECT treatment, many patients are
relieved of their depressive symptoms, which they did not experience with other
treatments. Now the exact mechanism of action or cause of why ECT is effective,
is still not known and research continues in that area.